so under our Constitution does the  president of the power to declare war on  I think this is a discussion not a trick  question and under a constitution does  the president of the power to declare  war you see yes or no we are okay all  right let me make it really easy for you  under the Constitution Congress has a  power to declare war correct it's not a  trick question sir  have you read the Constitution we will  do everything we are required to do mr.  Hoek have you read the Constitution I  have read the Constitution okay under  the Constitution the framers gave  Congress the power to declare war  correct Jesse yes or no this is my  understanding is that we're here to talk  about Iran foreign policy which I can do  under the Constitution the framers gave  Congress War Powers I bilocate should  have is it fear or message here I'm  gonna stop this line of questioning I'm  going to submit the US Constitution for  the record